i want to uh i want to first thank
everybody for for covering uh the story
not everyone comes legal pass and
showing up matters
and i want to thank leader mccarthy for
taking time out of his schedule and
making multiple
trips to the border that's important
it's certainly important to this
community i want to thank chairwoman
elise for showing up
you know gary palmer is also on our
leadership
in the republican leadership we have
three members of the republican
leadership showing up today we have
members from all all across our caucus
and it's a gloomy day here in eagle pass
it's been raining off and on it's very
windy it's a very gloomy day and you
know earlier today um border patrol were
able to recover the body of specialist
bishop evans and it just feels like a
gloomy
sad day
for many of us we're gonna come here
you're gonna turn the cameras off and
you're gonna go back to to where you
came from but there's a lot of us that
live here that work here that this is
home and that that gloomy day
doesn't go away
uh one thing i would say that this whole
crisis has done is it's brought people
together
uh it's unified it's unified certainly
our caucus is unified in making sure
the republican caucus is unified and
making sure that the border is going to
be secure it's unified and making sure
that innocent people don't have to live
through hell anymore and i know we're
unified in ensuring that we are going to
honor
specialist bishop evans because that man
is a hero and there are many heroes
walking among us we see them we've met
with them all throughout the day not all
of them are law enforcement
many of them are ranchers they're
farmers they're business owners they're
people that their voices have not been
heard
and they haven't been heard because
people do not show up
to eagle pass texas but yet here we are
we are unified in that
what i also say is we have solutions
it's one thing to come down here and
take a picture and say you know uh
rhetoric blame the administration for
everything that's wrong we haven't done
that we've listened to others our caucus
is constantly we have and you're going
to hear it from the group
we have answers
to we have solutions to some of these
issues it starts with title 42.
you know a year ago leader mccarthy and
and others came down to uh el paso
and the administration wanted to do it
away with title 42 a year ago and we
have fought them the republican party
has fought them every inch of the way
here we are a year later continuing to
fight and the fight isn't over
but i also say this is this is no longer
about parties
this is about people
everybody in this crisis
everybody's world is turned upside down
we've heard from ranchers that their
kids they can't go out and play
they they can't they have to carry
pistols all all you know when they walk
their properties
their childhoods have been stolen
people's lives have been stolen
this is about bringing everyone together
it starts with keeping title 42 what
you're seeing is democrats
democrats are now starting to be on
board as well because this does not stop
at a party i will stop there once again
i i thank everybody for showing up today
showing up is how is how we get to the
end of this crisis and i want to turn it
over to leader mccarthy
i want to thank congressman tony
gonzalez this is his district
one that he's worked very hard for this
is not our first trip down to the border
been coming here for quite some time
we welcome and want to ask the democrats
to join us actually
but before i begin i want to
i want to say a message
to bishop evan's grandmother who's
raised by his grandmother
our thoughts and prayers are with you
but your son your grandson did not die
in
he's a vain guard specialist
he's a human being
he risked his own life for a person he
did not know because he could not watch
that person drown
he gave his life
there are reports that the individual
he's trying to save may even been moving
drugs
but we want you to know that your
grandson did not die at bay
today we had
a very thorough tour starting with the
border agents i cannot thank them enough
for the job they do
they are pushed to the limits
you know
a former
secretary of homeland under obama
secretary johnson says 7 000 people a
day coming across your border is
unsustainable
that is where we are
30 days from now
president biden wants to lift title 42
everyone will tell you that that number
will more than double go to 18 000. if
it's unsustainable today what will it
look like a month from now
we ask them what their plan will be
no plan is given
we hear democrats on the other side of
the aisle say that they should not lift
it
they have the ability to say more than
just words they can vote you see in
congress
you have what is called a discharge
petition it only takes 218 members
doesn't matter if they're republican or
democrat a simple majority to sign a
discharge petition to bring a bill to
the floor it's been used many times
in different issues
we just need a handful of democrats to
join to bring the bill up for a vote
so if you believe title 42 shouldn't be
lifted
don't say it in a press release
say it in an action that you can make a
difference in
president biden's been in office more
than 40 years
the only known time that uh that he's
been to the border of my understanding
is one time when he drove through san
antonio
before he makes this decision he should
come here
he should look the border agents in the
eye and ask them what is the best
decision to make
he should spend the time
with the mayors
and the ranchers
in the city
workers that we just had lunch with
i saw a lot of things that were very
moving
but i watched a man
it was probably six five
was a rancher that has lived here his
life 20 miles from the border break down
in tears
to talk about the situation
that he told us he could not he and his
wife can't leave the lights on to their
house at night
because people will come his fear is
that people are going to get killed
that's what's happening right now
this is a responsibility of the federal
government i want to
i want to tell governor abbott thank you
it's a job you shouldn't have to do our
responsibility
but you're bringing the national guard
and others
here as a determined
to try to protect our borders
because of what this president's action
has done
when we walked through
the processing facility
i was shocked
i saw a line of individuals that had
just been
picked up
just a few minutes before
and a line of ice agents in front of
them
i watched him the ice agents with the
phone
putting around their face i thought it
was facial recognition i was right about
that but i was wrong with what it was
being used for
it was opening up the iphones that the
government was providing on
that's the way we're going to track
somebody that has entered illegally by
providing a phone and pay for their
calls
if president biden lifts title 42
what we see today will be much worse
a country without a secure border is not
a country
and no longer
is it just border cities
every city in america is a border city
and if you wonder how that can be
just read your newspaper
of who's died from fentanyl
in the last week
it is the number one killer
of americans between the ages of 18 and
45.
the number one
and where does fit and all come from
across this border
it's reaching
every walk of life in america today
and if you wonder if it will get worse
it's coming from 160 different countries
people are coming across this border
and in our last trip last march was we
first discovered speaking to the agents
that they are now catching people on the
terrorist watch list
that day it was from yemen and as we
first announced in the press conference
the democrats on the other side
congressman geigel said i was a liar
he sits on armed services he says he
gets intel reports
but when he found the truth the next day
he never said i was right nor did he
apologize
congresswoman escobar said i must be
fibbing with the truth
well now they know the truth and it's
not just those two
more than 42. i want them to ask this
question
why is somebody on the terrace watch
list from a country far away
entering america
who are they talking to and what do they
have planned
it's a responsibility to protect all
americans and that's not happening and
if title 42 is lifted
it will be much worse
it's not just unsustainable now it'll be
uncontrollable then
and if a democrat believes it should be
lifted come here
and see what's happening before you make
that decision
the president owes it to the american
people
to at least find the truth before he
makes a decision
with that i'd like to turn it over to
our conference chair elise stefani
thank you leader mccarthy and thank you
to representative tony gonzalez who
works so hard every day on behalf of the
communities he represents
you know when i think back to one of my
first conversations with tony the number
one issue he talked about that was
important to his district is addressing
the historic border crisis we've heard
that firsthand from border patrol agents
i hear that from border patrol agents in
my district along the northern border
who have been transferred here over and
over and over again but make no mistake
this is not just a crisis in south texas
this is a united states of america
crisis and it's a crisis as a result of
joe biden and house democrats failed
policies this has gotten worse and worse
every single month it's the worst past
year since we've been keeping track of
the numbers and we know it's only going
to get significantly worse with joe
biden's decision to lift title 42. today
i had the opportunity as did my
colleagues to tour with our boat border
patrol and the two captains of our boat
were the ones that recovered the body of
bishop evans think about the emotional
turmoil the emotional anguish that these
border patrol agents are going through
every day in addition to the national
guard and their families our hearts
break house republicans are unified in
securing the border and providing the
support we need to our border patrol and
our communities in south texas and
across the country i now want to turn it
over to the house republican policy
chair gary palmer
thank you elise thank you leader
mccarthy and congressman gonzalez
for bringing us to the border
what we're witnessing is
both a a national tragedy and a human
tragedy i had the opportunity to speak
with
a few of the members of the national
guard who were part of
specialist heaven's unit and the emotion
is all over their face they're
struggling with this and as
leader mccarthy said our heart our
thoughts and prayers are with his
grandmother and and we're determined
that he did not die in vain we also had
the opportunity to talk with some of the
ranchers and farmers and city leaders
and
at the end of this press conference
you're going to to be asking us
questions but you need to go talk to
those people
you need to understand the human tragedy
is taking place
because we have left our borders open
people cannot live their lives
because of it their kids cannot grow up
the way children should be able to grow
up because we've left the border open
the human tragedy goes beyond
the number of deaths from fentanyl it's
105 000 the highest ever recorded and
that's probably underreported by 15 or
20 percent according to the people i've
talked to because so many families don't
want it on the death certificate that
their loved one died from an overdose
but we were also told just this since
the first of this year there's a hundred
a thousand a hundred thousand got aways
we don't know who those people are and i
ask
could those be
young women that are being brought
across the border and traffic for sex
and the answer is
very likely
this is not is a national security issue
because they're known terrorists who've
been picked up we do not know who hasn't
been picked up and i want to remind the
democrats it only took 19
to carry out
september 11th
so i would just like to again
encourage you
to go beyond the typical reporting that
you do about a trip to the border and
talk to the people out in in texas who
are impacted by this and talk to the
people who are doing their job every day
to defend this border
with that i'd like to invite michael
guest congressman michael guest from
mississippi to the podium
i'd like to echo the comments with
meeting my colleagues our hearts and our
prayers go out
to specialist heavens
someone who died doing what he loved
someone who died protecting his country
someone who died helping others
we must never forget the service of the
men and women who wear the uniform
who protect this country each and every
day
who fight to see that the rule of law is
enforced
i'll tell you throughout our visit we
have encountered one thing from every
person that we've spoken with
that this is the worst they have ever
seen the southwest border without
exception every man and woman whether it
be those serving in law enforcement or
those serving the community community
echoed those remarks
we know that last month there were 221
000 immigrants who were apprehended
across our southwest border we've been
told that once title 42 expires
and it's set to expire in less than 30
days that that number will grow
exponentially
the department of homeland security has
said as possibly as many as eighteen
thousand immigrants a day will flood
into our communities
as we met with community leaders
community leaders told us two things
one they said that they felt abandoned
that this administration that the
federal government had abandoned them
and then they gave one very simple plea
please provide help
to those members we met with today i
want them to know that those pleas do
not fall on deaf ears
that myself and my colleagues behind us
and we will take those pleas to
washington dc
and that we will fight on their behalf
we will fight on behalf of the men and
women who stand behind us who stand here
on this border protecting this great
country that we love at this time i will
turn the podium over to representative
chip roy
thanks mike
thanks tony thanks leader mccarthy
throughout my entire life in public
service i've heard a lot of my
democratic colleagues
claim the mantle of compassion
there is nothing compassionate about
this
nothing
last friday
a teenage girl who had been
raped
prostituted put into the sex trafficking
trade
served as the basis for the arrest of a
mexican national who had been deported
15 times
that happened in san antonio texas
that's a real life it's a real human
being
there are stash houses within miles of
here stash houses in houston san antonio
human beings being trafficked for profit
and it takes
a lot of effort to get
the media to come down here
and focus on this
the ranchers that we met with this
morning that i've met with dozens of
time that tony's met with dozens of time
hundreds of times
where are you guys
on a daily basis
when their lives are getting turned
upside down
are you asking our democratic colleagues
like you tend to go stick a microphone
in our face asking us which thing we've
done or not done
have you asked any of our democratic
colleagues why they have not
signed a discharge petition to ensure
title 42 enforcement which we've had
filed for a year
we filed it last april
an entire year it's been sitting there
now we get attention
a month out
but here's the real truth
title 42
is a band-aid on a gunshot wound
it's not actual border security
it's important
but it represents the ability to turn
people away and actually secure the
border
but we've got to actually do the hard
work of having a sovereign nation secure
a border so that migrants don't get
killed
the seven hundred to a thousand they're
in body trailers
the local officials have to go rent to
put bodies in
the ranchers who find dead bodies on
their property
the bodies you find in the river on a
daily basis that border patrol
has to go find in the river every day
that's my ask of you and the press
ask every single member of the house
representatives on the other side of the
aisle why they won't sign a discharge
petition to move title 42 but more
importantly
stand up for a secure border
remember that it was a democrat semester
reyes who helped us build a fence in el
paso 15 years ago that is actually
helping the flow there
this should not be a partisan issue to
have a sovereign nation
that's what this is about but it's about
the humanity it's about the people dying
from fentanyl poisonings about the
people being put in the sex trafficking
trade it's about the ranchers it's about
the people throughout this country
getting harmed because this
administration led by the president and
secretary marcus who i look forward to
seeing on thursday by the way in the
judiciary committee
they won't do their job and they leave
the job to the governor and texas dps
and our national guard in texas
with that i'm going to turn over my
friend miss taylor green from georgia
first i'd like to thank congressman tony
gonzalez for bringing us here um and
leader mccarthy thank you very much i'm
from georgia and this is my first real
border trip and i just want to tell you
right now this isn't about political
parties and it shouldn't be nothing
about politics this should be about
securing the united states border
respecting our laws respecting our law
enforcement respecting the families and
the businesses that live right here
along our border
and then also
realizing by the sheer numbers and the
facts and the the information that we
learned today
that our president
that the united states elected he is
serving as our president well he is the
greatest business partner to the cartels
that has ever existed
because everything he's doing along with
the democrats is enriching them
by
so much money hundreds of millions of
dollars and even more
the human suffering that has happened
and is happening and will happen if
title 42 is repealed and lifted and the
amount of people that are expected to
come across this border starts coming
this will bring human suffering death
and crime like we have never seen and
we're already seeing it at numbers and
elevated numbers that we've never
witnessed before in our lives
imagine being a mother and you can't let
your children go play outside in the
yard because there are people that you
don't know who they are invading your
country coming across your property
and imagine what they could do to your
kids imagine being a woman and you're
just trying to get your groceries out of
your car to carry them in the house and
you are faced with men
who don't even belong in your in your
carport and that's where they are
because they invaded our country
now imagine finding out that your
grandson drowned in this river behind us
because he went in to save someone's
life
who is
rumored to be smuggling drugs into
america these are the things that
shouldn't be happening
but they're happening
and the democrats are doing nothing
about it
well here's what's going to happen house
republicans are committed and we are all
together going to do something about
this problem to secure our border and
most of all
protect our country and our families and
our businesses and support our law
enforcement border patrol
and give them the resources that they
need so that america can be respected
again our laws can be respected again
and we can have a secure nation for
every single american not for just one
group or another but for all of us
thank you very much with that i'd like
to turn it over to representative diana
harshberger
well it's a pleasure to be here thank
you tony thank you leader mccarthy for
inviting me you know i'm i'm not from a
border state i'm from tennessee
but every state in the union is going to
be a border state um
i i don't know what to say about what
i've seen today
it's heartbreaking that a young man lost
his his life
a grandmother will go home and she won't
have a grandson
but it happens every day
with these illegal
drugs being smuggled across the border
and i don't know of a family that's not
been touched
at all
by someone who's lost a son or a
daughter or a mom or a dad because of
the illegal use of fentanyl
methamphetamines the numbers are unreal
you know the cartels are the biggest
national criminal threat to our country
period and we're allowing this to happen
and our government is becoming
the largest
human smuggler of illegal aliens period
this is a travesty
a sovereign
sovereign nation has borders
and i want the border patrol in all law
enforcement in texas to know that we're
going to do whatever we can to help stop
this
and it happens in november
we have to stop the bleeding
these people are asking us to help these
ranchers are having their
it's trespassing no one's taking charge
they can't get anybody to come out when
somebody comes women are in their homes
being attacked sometimes by illegals you
know these are stories we heard today
it's unbelievable and the rest of the
country needs to wake up
and they need to see what's happening
right here
del rio eagle pass the rio grande the
numbers we heard today are staggering
it's unbelievable
and i want them to know that i'll do
whatever within my power
to help them get the funds they need to
help them with whatever they need
to stop this situation
the law is the law and if you want to
change it you need to legislate it not
executive order it
and the last thing i'll say is
lawlessness breeds lawlessness and
that's what we're seeing right here
and our nation can't handle this
with that i'll turn it over to
representative blake moore
thank you diana
i'd like to just first
sincerely thank uh representative tony
gonzalez he's an incredible friend of
mine we're freshmen together
and speak directly to
the texans in the 23rd district
you have somebody in tony gonzalez
that cares more about this issue than
anybody that i know
um but he doesn't just he doesn't just
show up by bringing numerous
numerous groups down here to just walk
us through it and show us the reality
we're on the house floor and i'm asking
him questions about this before
i go on a town hall in my town in my in
in my district of utah
your representative cares deeply about
this and he cares about solutions and he
talked about it today
and he will continue to
focus on that
i apologize he mentioned it's a somber
day and i'd like to just echo the
condolences for
specialist evans and to his grandmother
that didn't need to happen
and we will continue to work and fight
so his life is not in vain you see
his his fellow guardsmen
his leadership here today sharing us
with us the reality look i
appreciate
all the cameras and stuff
in my freshman term i've
i haven't done a lot of this i haven't
spoken a lot to broad media i've
but what i have done is
what the point that i want to make
like i said i'm in utah we're tucked in
the intermountain region of the of the
us it's very very far from northern east
all the borders of our nation
and
what i have done is had countless town
halls with my community
and there hasn't been a single town hall
an interaction that i've had where they
haven't asked about this
they haven't asked about the border
situation
this is affecting every single community
in america
and it's all something we can avoid and
it's reiterated by what we just heard
from the general over the uh the air
national guard here in texas
was that you have to address the policy
address the policy
there is policies that work from the
previous administration
address it don't let politics
guide you
address the policy enforce the remaining
mexico policy it's a compassionate
program that will keep border activity
to a minimum right we are all for
embracing where there there's a
comprehensive approach to being able to
address this but we have to enforce
policy we have to strengthen our border
and that will allow for us to be able to
continue to address a comprehensive
approach and i've heard that from
business leaders today and from
individuals that are faced with this
dire situation and i just wanted to
emphasize how much
we care about this and we care about
making it right thank you i'll introduce
next
representative randy weber
well thank you blake
and buenas tardes hombres
randy webber yo espero que todante in
good afternoon my name is randy weber i
hope all american citizens are paying
attention this is a sad day
we're down here on the border
as you know we lost a guardsman
he gave his life for somebody that he
never even knew
he was willing to lay down his life
bishop evans was willing to have that
life for american citizens but he laid
down his life for somebody who didn't
have a right to be here
he should be remembered i hope his
grandmother takes solace on that jesus
said no greater love has a man than he
lay down his life for his fellow man and
bishop evans exemplified that
and i want to also echo what our great
leader said when he said thank you
governor abbott
i was and i want to say thank you texas
legislature i was there in 2009-2012
when we put four hundred million dollars
on the border because the federal
government wouldn't do its job
now it's three billion dollars the state
legislature is putting on the border
shouldn't be
absolutely shouldn't be
biden bears responsibility for this i
don't see how he sleeps well at night
it's just not our national guardsman who
lost his life you all have seen the
stories of infants of young children of
women that have been raped sexually
abused young ladies young girls
biden bears responsibility i don't this
is his motor border crisis i don't see
how he sleeps well at night this is
about my seventh or eighth trip here
it's getting worse and worse and worse
and president biden bears that blame
thank you all for being here i'm gonna
yield back to our great leader